mais bon je vous fais délicat belle
vente ou 10000 madame monsieur bonjour
invités de 5 à 10 ce matin le docteur
emmanuel florent bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes allergologue et addictologue
mais un généraliste médecin généraliste
et avec plusieurs de vos confrères vous
allez animer une série de conférences
qui commence ce soir à 19h à l'hôtel de
ville de fort de france au sixième étage
le thème asthme allergies ici c'était
l'ère de la maison qu'est ce que vous
cherchez à montrer que l'air intérieur
est plus pollué qu'à l'extérieur
évidemment on a des différents éléments
qui potable penser que les intérieurs
peut être très pollué donc généralement
parle d' habitude de l'extérieur ce
matin on a parlé de l'indicé atmo qui
est à 5 on voit bien que ya une grise
est à l'extérieur tu que qui a un niveau
de pollution avec la densité automobile
donc on est beaucoup plus habitués à
parler de l'air extérieur pour autant on
constate que à l'intérieur du domicile
et à l'intérieur des bâtiments il peut y
avoir des éléments très très polluants
et qui comme on passe la plupart du
temps à l'intérieur donc on est
confronté à ces particules et à ses
éléments de pollution qui peuvent
altérer notre santé ion notamment notre
santé respiratoire
justement quelles sont ses sources de
pollution à l'intérieur alors que ce
soit d'un domicile au travail on peut
être exposé à des particuliers par
exemple dans les bâtiments neufs ou là
où il y avait beaucoup de produits qui
ont été utilisés par les élèves parlent
l'équipement du bâtiment donc on peut
être exposé à des émanations de
particules soit des vernis soit des des
substances qu'on a utilisé la colle ou
d'autres matériaux qui peuvent eux se
diffuser dans l'ain dans l'air ils vont
peut inhaler certains produits mais
c'est pas pour faire peur en mémoire des
bâtiments neufs peuvent avoir des
émanations de polluants venant de
produits chimiques qui ont été utilisés
pendant la construction neuve flux sont
dangereux par forcément mais bon on
j'ai eu le retour de quelques cas de
bâtiments ou une fois que les personnes
ont aménagé dedans surtout dans le
milieu du travail qui ont signalé des
jeunes respire
3 parfois des émanations des particules
de produits volatiles qu'ils ont été
utilisés pendant la construction mais
bon ça c'est c'est une parenthèse on a
généralement à l'été haut des bâtiments
surtout ici chez nous on est sur une île
doit qu'on ait d'humidité très élevé 81%
taux d'humidité
on peut avoir des moisissures qui loge
dans les coulisses et dans les plus faux
plafonds et qui pose d'énormes problèmes
d'ailleurs c'est l'une des
préoccupations des pouvoirs publics
puisqu'il a été décrite et des études
qui doivent être menées sur l'ensemble
du département donc pour essayer de
comprendre l'écologie des moisissures
chez nous et qui pose d'énormes
problèmes que ce soit dans les bâtiments
mais surtout en milieu domestique donc
je pense que les auditeurs qui nous
écoutent
la plupart d'entre eux doivent observer
chez ed sur les murs des salles peut
être des épis dans le plafond que les
têtes et moisissures et surtout dans les
placards et il faut il faut tout
regarder mais il souffre il faut aussi
faire attention à ce qu'on utilise vous
le disiez le l'immeuble aussi peuvent
être des sources les peintures les
désodorisants les matériaux de
construction n'a parlé les fumées les
tapis la clim les bougies parfumées
qu'on aime bien qu'on reçoit une bougie
parfumée
ça fait toujours bien mais bon ça aussi
ça pose problème et lançant également
merci pour cette question qui est très
très qui aboie de même le coeur du sujet
puisque nos habitudes de vie peuvent
être à l'origine de pollutions de coeur
on voit bien que la tendance actuelle
c'est d'utiliser des huiles essentielles
et des vaporisateurs kiki et malkin qui
crée une certaine ambiance aromatiques à
l'intérieur du domicile mais on appelle
quand même à la vigilance parce que ces
émanations peuvent être toxiques pour
les voies respiratoires et générer des
de l'asthme pour les personnes qui sont
vulnérables
mais en même temps de choix
d'aménagement intérieur par exemple l'
usage de moquette
de meubles en tissu le lusage de fêtes
de sujets qu'on met pour découvrir
l'intérieur que peuvent être des sources
de ce qu'on appelle des bus contaminants
notamment des acariens acariens
moisissures mais notamment des acariens
qui constituent 80 % de la composition
de la poussière de maison
donc il est important que les auditeurs
comprennent que le choix des matériaux
qu'ils utilisent pour aménager
l'intérieur peut générer une source de
pollution biologique importantes et
notamment par rapport aux acariens
j'en prends pour preuve veulent
maintenant une habitude nouvelle
d'utiliser les petits coussins vous
découvrirez l'écho canapé d'intérieur
donc on va acheter des coussins et puis
toute la famille s'installe seul aux
gars canadien on regarde la télé les
enfants qui tiennent leur petit coussin
4e
donc ça c'est aussi des sources
d'hébergement pour les acariens qui vont
se multiplier par centaines de milliards
et qui vont composer la poussière de
maison
cette poussière étant composé de plus de
90% de molécules de particules
d'acariens va générer une irritation des
voies respiratoires générer de la
rhinite et surtout de l'asthme
alors si ce que c'est ce que j'allais
vous vous demandez quels sont les
symptômes qu'est-ce que question et 70
quand on a une mauvaise qualité de l'air
à l'intérieur qu'est ce qu'on a que ça
commence par quoi déjà une irritation de
la gorge les yeux qu'est ce qu'il ya
alors l'ensemble des voies respiratoires
peut aller atteindre que dans les voies
respiratoires j'aime souvent dire que
les yeux face et d'erreurs et spin 3
puisque les yeux sont exposées à l'air
donc il ya une irritation des yeux qui
les gens ils se frottent les yeux
souvent il ya 7 gratuit aussi de
l'arrière gorge qui est souvent le
symptôme principal les gens me disent
que j'ai tout le temps été hors de la
gauche qui grattent et puis ils ont
épaissi même l'oreille interne il
gratuit de l'intérieur donc ce sont des
signes d'irritation des voies
respiratoires
et puis pour descendre un peu plus bas
au niveau des poumons doigt que c'est la
gêne pu être traduites par une toux une
petite toux sèche
qui vous revient souvent souvent et
c'est tout elle est aussi bien dans la
journée que dans la nuit et pour les
enfants c'est un signe caractéristique
un enfant qui le soir une fois au lit se
met à tousser part au début de son
sommet pendant toute la nuit doit
alerter parce que c'est un signe d'asie
qui se développe
on a souvent tendance à confondre glace
et la crise d'asthme et c'est pour cela
aussi que nous menons ces journées de
confiance et pour sensibiliser la
population pour pouvoir a alerté parce
que c'est déjà la petite toux sèche
c'est déjà l'enfant qui quand il joue
avec les autres îles kouriles tous c'est
déjà l'enfant ou l'adulte quand ils
rient aux éclats et le rire se termine
par une part des cannes de tout donc ça
ce sont des signes alerte qui peuvent
orienter pour dire il faut consulter il
faut faire un bilan parce que c'est un
asthme qui se développe encore une fois
l'asthme ce n'est pas la crise dans la
crise d'asthme mais on est déjà dans la
complications de la maladie dans un
stade très très très avancé alors ce que
l'asthme commence déjà souvent pas cette
petite gratuit au niveau de l'offre au
fond de la gorge et ses petites ou
sèches
alors que faut-il faire est-ce qu'il ya
digest est une façon de prévenir
est ce qu'il ya de bons gestes à avoir
que compte que peut-on faire
alors quand on opère ses symptômes
que ce soit les yeux qui pour les tigres
est et puis bien là la clac où il est
important de consulter son médecin et de
solliciter un bilan allergologique parce
que ça permettra déjà de faire l'
enquête et de voir quelles particules
ces personnes sont exposées
on a abordé le problème de des acariens
desbiaux contaminants mais on peut aussi
aborder un sujet nouveau aussi c'est le
la tendance à avoir des animaux de
compagnie à l'intérieur de sa maison de
vie avec des petits animaux les hamsters
les chats les chiens dans des
appartements à l'intérieur de la maison
donc ces animaux sont faits pour vivre à
l'extérieur et le fait de les infirmer
avec nous confiner entre quatre murs
on augmente les la consultation de ces
partis ne donnons pas avec son chalet
avec son chien c'est pas recommandée
parce que c'est l'animal est fait pour
vivre à l'extérieur et le fait d'avoir
des concentrations importantes dans un
appartement dans une maison ou l'eire
n'est pas suffisamment ou renouvelés
expose aussi à des imitations de la part
de ces bio contaminants mais de notre
côté aussi en dehors des bio
contaminants on peut parler aussi de
l'usagé qu'on fait des produits ménagers
qui constitue une sous ces normes de
pollution
parce que en attendant ce chine aussi a
utilisé beaucoup de javel
parce que j'avais le nez 3 to sah
purifie sa chasse touzit dont je suis la
poudre la poudre de javel liquide de
javel concentrer tout ça pour nettoyer
l'été hors de son domicile et lassé des
expositions à des émanations très très
toxique et irritants pour les voies
respiratoires
on voit que au niveau marketing sur les
grandes surfaces ya des étalages avec
des rayons entiers bien fourni en
produits de toutes sortes pour nettoyer
les terres la maison on constate
aujourd'hui que ces produits peuvent
avoir un taux de rim annonce très élevé
donc ils peuvent rester pendant des
années à l'intérieur du domicile donc on
fait que cumuler les particules qui sont
polluantes et qui auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
comment alors assainir son environnement
est ce que l'on doit comment assainir et
qu'est ce que l'on doit faire et ce
qu'on doit porter un masque alors à ce
moment là déjà éviter les produits à
base de javel et éviter l' usage de
serpentins
les encens et éviter le éviter les
petits va appeler les vaporisateurs là
qu'ils les diffuseurs qui à base
d'huiles essentielles
parce que tous ces éléments là nous
envoie des émanations volatiles qui sont
irritants pour les voies respiratoires
knox et c'est le but de ces journées de
sensibiliser la population et de dire
que voilà comment on peut protéger sa
santé améliorer la qualité de l'air
intérieur parce que c'est dans ce sens
là que nous arrivons à avoir une qualité
d'air et une pour améliorer notre
fonction respiratoire et il faut aérer
la maison y fera énormément parce que
bon on constate aussi c'est une tendance
est encore on vit enfermé pour des
raisons de sécurité pour des raisons
aussi de protection contre les
moustiques et les insectes nuisibles
on a ces petites bestioles à l'écu
liquid là qu'on appelle les envahissent
maintenant temps que les gens pendant ce
davantage air s'affirmer tout ça il faut
aérer et puis bon on peut aussi
solliciter le fait que dans les choix
d'aménagement urbain à venir qu'on
puisse plus voir des types
d'aménagements et de type d'architecturé
qui permettent une meilleure ventilation
une meilleure luminosité de nos
appartements parce que les immeubles
construits l'an on constate qu'ils ne
sont pas suffisamment aéré et ça ça crée
aussi une source de problèmes bond
énorme au vent on va en parler on va en
parler envie revenir
ce qu'il faut par exemple eu tunisie dit
purificateurs d'air
est-ce que c'est efficace alors on peut
pas problème des moisissures recourir
des déshumidificateurs électrique ça
mange très bien donc on a dans les
grandes surfaces spécialisées doté d'un
humidificateur tant que ça c'est
important qu'on puisse eux si on a les
moyens financiers de pouvoir s'équiper
de ces des humidificateurs parce que ça
pourrait aider à résoudre le problème
des moisissures
à quel moment nous sommes le plus le
plus exposé est ce que nous ont exposé
le jour la nuit parce que la nuit
s comme les plus vulnérables à quel
moment nous sommes le plus exposé alors
c'est les particules une fois qu'on les
a utilisées elles sont présentes en
permanence dans que l'exposition peut
être plus important de la journée
parfait par le fait que l'air extérieur
peut nous ramener aussi des particules
de venant de l'extérieur surtout pas
pour la circulation automobile
oui à les particules de soufre et les
émanations de diesel qui peuvent arriver
chez nous malgré nous donc ça ça
augmente encore la pollution intérieure
mais de toute façon à l'intérieur du
domicile
il y à une permanence des particules que
nous utilisons les soit par les produits
ménagers ou soit par les bio
contaminants que nous utilisons par
exemple les lexus d'acariens où les
sources des revenants des animaux noxa
c'est des particules bio contaminantes
qui reste en permanence alors ce sera ma
dernière question quand on est dans un
lieu de terreur travail où on se trouve
dans un espace clos sans possibilité
d'aération avec une clim commune là tout
le bâtiment
quels sont les risques alors là il ya
des risques ainsi par pau climatisation
centrale avec deux des sources de dos il
ya des clean qui utilise une sorte de
chaudières d'eau qui refroidit l'air et
l'entretien de la tunise ation de ces
crimes centre elle est importante doc il
est on constate souvent des problèmes
émanant de ces sources de climatisation
centrale parce que l'entretien pose
problème on laisse à désirer et où les
salariés les passionnés les personnes
qui travaillent dans ces bâtiments
souffrent souvent de toux d'irritation
des yeux d'irritation des fois explique
être supérieur et c'est un réel problème
peau en termes de d'écologie d'un
bâtiment
merci docteur florent on va rappeler
tout au long de la journée les
différents les différents les
différentes conférences
je remercie sa oqali terminé bonne
journée merci
merci à la librairie des conseils bien
pratique ce matin pour la pollution de
nos intérieurs on y reviendra bien
évidemment